The science of black
holes is so challenging
that some scientists
question whether they
exist at all.
Despite their fearsome
reputation.
We've never actually
seen one.
Black holes are
everywhere there, all
over the universe.
They're all throughout
our galaxy. But that
doesn't mean that they're
easy to find.
They're black and space
is black.
And black on black is
kind of hard to see in a
picture of space.
This is paradoxical
because scientists
believe black holes are
born and some of the
brightest explosions in
the universe.
Rising from the corpses
of detonated stars many
times larger than our
sun.
The star that burns for
10 million years
collapses to form a
black hole in a period of
seconds.
As it collapses, the
outer region of the star
hits the core,
triggering a huge
explosion, a supernova.
We see the bang, but not
what's left behind.
A dead core with the
enormous mass of the star
crushed down into an
infinitesimal, tiny area.
From this minuscule high
mass core.
A black hole is born.
The flow of gravity is so
strong that nothing can
escape. Not even light.
But how can scientists
claim that black holes
exist if we can't even
see them?
You could say that about
the existence of the
atom. We knew they had
existed for decades,
centuries before.
We had actually seen one
in some sort of imaging
device. And so it's the
same sort of thing with
black holes.
Just because you can't
see it doesn't mean it's
not there. Not seeing
black holes, but knowing
they're there is a
possibility, just like we
know that wind is there
even though we can't see
air.
Air is invisible, but
when the wind blows, its
effects can be measured.
It's the same with black
holes.
You just need to know
what to look for.
While they emit no light
themselves.
Black holes are
tremendous sources of x
rays, and that's because
as things get close to a
black hole, they're
accelerated by the
gravity and they can
heat up to millions of
degrees. Million degree
gas gives you lots of x
rays.
To find and measure these
telltale x rays.
Scientists turned to the
new Star Space Telescope
in 2017.
It spots a burst of x
rays in a cluster called
47 to Cana at the edge
of the Milky Way.
When scientists analyze
the data, they realize
they're looking at two
objects orbiting each
other very closely.
All we see is that
there's a star being
ripped apart and gas is
spiraling down to a very
dense, very dark object.
So something weird is
going on.
As one of the.
Objects accretes matter
off the other.
It causes it to emit x
rays, and those x rays
can be used then to
trace out the orbits and
therefore extract the
mass.
When scientists work out
the size and mass of the
two objects they find.
The first is the fading
corpse of a sun like
star. And while the
second object is tiny, it
has the mass of a giant.
Is this an elusive black
hole?
What we're talking about
here is an object that is
very massive, very
small, very dense with
intense gravity.
But it turns out there
are lots of different
ways to create an object
like that.
There is another type of
ultra dense object out
there in the universe
called a neutron star.
Neutron stars form in the
same way we think black
holes form when stars
die, explode, but then
collapse down into a
tiny ball of matter.
The gravitational
attraction of a neutron
star is enormous,
pulling in gas, dust and
asteroids. But light can
still escape.
Black holes and neutron
stars are kind of
cousins. But in the case
of a neutron star, it
didn't have quite enough
mass to collapse out of
control. So you can sort
of think of it as just
barely hanging back from
collapsing into a black
hole.
The tiny object
discovered by NuStar does
have enormous mass.
But size and mass alone
are not enough to prove
it's a black hole.
Cosmologists need more
evidence.
They can't see black
holes.
But is there another
way? What if they could
hear them?
Think of two massive cars
colliding.
Boom. When they do, they
radiate sound and then we
can tell whether or not
that collision occurred
and maybe even how far
away it was.
It's like that when
black holes collide.
So by listening for a
black hole crash.
Could scientists
conclusively prove they
exist?
There are gravitational
waves going through this
room all the time.
Every time I move my
hands like I just did, I
create gravitational
waves. The problem is
gravity is so weak that
you don't detect those
gravitational waves.
In order to detect those
disturbances in space and
time, you have to have
cataclysmic events
involving massive
objects.
Black holes are some of
the densest objects in
the universe. So we
should be able to hear
and measure the waves
created when they
collide. Legault.
The long interferometry
gravitational wave
observatory listens for
waves that can come from
over a billion light
years away.
In 2017, Legault heard
an enormous crash.
Two very massive objects
collided at near the
speed of light. And one
of the most energetic
events that we have ever
witnessed in the history
of humankind.
Two ultra heavy, ultra
dense objects whirl
around each other,
hurling powerful
gravitational waves
through space.
The closer they fall
toward each other, the
more gravitational
energy they throw out.
Finally they collide in
one of the most violent
events in the universe.
The smash sends out
immense gravitational
waves that ripple across
intergalactic space until
eventually Legault
detects them.
Listening to a
gravitational wave is
like listening to a
musical instrument.
If it's making certain
tones or certain
vibrations, you can
figure out the size of
the musical instrument,
the type of the musical
instrument. Who's
playing the musical
instrument?